paxton thank you for having the courage
of your convictions brah
maybe i'll use our place in this
democracy to fight for what we believe
to be right and follow your example yeah
you should follow her example by
you know shouting about how abortion is
just an
injurable moral good i mean look how far
they've pushed on culture so yesterday
there was a video making the rounds on
the internet of a a girl in texas who
was valedictorian of her high school and
instead of reading
her valedictory address she which had
been pre-approved which is typically how
this is done
at high schools all around the nation
instead she got up and she decided to
rant about abortion and how abortion was
a wonderful thing for women and she was
cheered for this
hillary clinton remember her husband
said safe legal and rare this girl was
like if we don't have abortion women
can't succeed in american life
and hillary clinton was cheering it
here's what this uh this young woman had
to say
i have dreams and hopes and ambitions
every girl graduating today does and we
have spent
our entire lives working towards our
future
and without our input and without our
consent
our control over that future has been
stripped away from us
i am terrified that if my contraceptives
fail
i am terrified that if i am raped
then my hopes and aspirations and dreams
and efforts for my future will no longer
matter
okay what she's saying is morally
horrifying right she's saying that her
hopes and aspirations rely on killing a
baby in the womb that's what she's
actually saying okay she throws in rape
there
but the reality is that the vast
majority of people who are having
abortions in the united states as in on
the order of
over 99 are not people who have been
raped or are victims of incest
the vast majority of people have
abortions in the united states are
having abortions because they don't want
the baby
okay and that it but that is treated not
only as mainstream political rhetoric
these days that abortion is a
fundamental good
it's a guarantor of women's rights it's
a guarantor that you're able to do what
you want in the workplace now it turns
out that there are other ways to avoid
getting pregnant
namely don't have sex use birth control
use a couple forms of birth control
you could theoretically do what my wife
and i did and get married before you
have babies right there are lots of
things you can do
but the idea here that abortion is the
sole guarantor that it is the last
available
battlement before women's rights are
breached is an insane one but the left
has fully embraced this
to the point where andrew cuomo was
lighting up buildings in new york pink
after they passed a basic abortion on
demand
up until point of birth bill in new york
who's pushing the culture war
the people who are pushing the culture
or are the folks on the left again
hillary clinton
tweeted out this took guts thank you for
not saying silent paxton
did it take guts though because she knew
she'd be celebrated beto o'rourked
tweeted paxton
thank you for having the courage of your
convictions and inspiring texas with
your refusal to accept injustice
as the price of participation in civic
life bra
maybe i'll use our place in this
democracy to fight for what we believe
to be right and follow your example yeah
you should follow her example by
you know shouting about how abortion is
just an
injurable moral good she's an incredible
moral good
except injustice as the price of
participation again no one is
forcing her to get pregnant nobody is
suggesting
that she cannot make the decision not to
have a baby
okay but once you get once you have a
baby in your womb that is an independent
human
speaking of the culture see here's the
thing culture wars are
a bunch of little battles and every time
there's a little battle people on the
left say
well why are you even pushing back on
this again this is all part of the
broader gas lighting
so the broader gas lighting is we didn't
start the culture where you start you
guys are the culture warriors and we're
like wait i'm a culture warrior because
i say that abortion is bad and men and
women exist
i'm confused like how did that make me
the aggressor in this culture war
and this is why the media are constantly
using the language of republicans pounds
every time something happens
that the left is pushing it's
republicans pounds the story is not
republicans pouncing
the story is the left pushing an
aggressive move
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like
and subscribe to help keep our videos on
the front line of the fight and top of
your feed